hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
discover how single-cell RNA sequencing
provides deeper insights and to lung
cancer biology I'm Alexis Krause of
laborat and I'll be our moderator for
today's event today's educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots and
brought to you by Illumina and 10 x
genomics to learn more about our
sponsors please visit Illumina comm and
10 extra electron now let's get started
before you begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab found at the top right of
the presentation window or report your
problems by clicking on the ask a
question box located on the far left to
your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I not
present today's speakers for nineteen
point a system professor Faculty of
Medicine
kayuu Leuven Anika branching Regional
Marketing Manager Enya 10x genomics and
dr. Powell's Ajax segment marketing
manager cell biology Illumina for
complete bio disease on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen our speakers will now
begin their presentations
hello and thank you for spending time
with us this afternoon before we get the
chance to hear more about the exciting
research from Barnard I will give you a
brief introduction to 10x genomics and
how you can transform your understanding
of genomics transcriptomics and
epigenomics
I'll see all no human biology is
immensely complex from the trillions of
cells and types in the human body to the
genes and nucleotides found in the DNA
of those cells to the structure of the
chromatin to the translation of genes
which differ for cell type the
complexity is enormous yet thanks to
your work there are many knowns but
still so much left to discover and as an
example defining this complexity has
been taking on by the human cell Atlas
global consortium and much like the
human genome project fundamentally
changed the way we explore biology more
than a decade ago the human cell Atlas
will again change the way that we
explore biology ultimately to influence
the treatment of disease it is ten axis
mission to accelerate these studies and
reveal these complexities through the
solutions we offer
and the core technology that drives the
scalability and ease of use of our
product is a microfluidic system for
masses throughput a molecular bar coding
and partitioning of reagents into nano
liter sized reaction vessels
the tenants portfolio started out with
our first implementation of the gem code
fluidics technology with linked reads
for genome and exome sequencing and
anova assembly we then extended the
technology for single cell capabilities
with single cell gene expression single
cell immune profiling solutions and
innovating on our technology for single
cells env solution a newly launched set
of products include the single-cell
attack solution for analysis of open
chromatin in epigenetics also the
implementation of feature bar coding
technology which allows simultaneous
measurements alongside the single cell
gene expression and single cell immune
profiling solutions in the same cells
and our newest announcement the
availability of a substantially improved
single cell gene expression solution so
let's take a closer look at these
different offerings so gene expression
analysis is a standard and robust tool
for understanding the transcriptome but
traditional bulk RNA seek methods really
just give you singular data points per
sample for the scale and use of 10x you
can profile tens of thousands of cells
and multiple samples at a time and
beautifully see the clusters and sub
clusters of cell types to the right here
is a two-dimensional view of a tease me
plot where each dot is a cell clustered
based on multi-dimensional information
and its similarity then color-coded by
known cell markers
then check the single-cell gene
expression functionality and applied it
for the study of the adaptive immune
system here you can not only identify
the subtypes of immune cells based on
gene expression profiles but also in
t-cells characterized pair alpha and
beta chain receptor sequences or in
b-cells
identify paired heavy and light chain
immune globulin sequences giving vdj
recombination insights and clonal type
information all in the same cell oh and
we can't forget about one of our
favorite model systems the mouse which
we added to the portfolio earlier this
year and also earlier this year we
innovated on our single-cell RNA
solutions and apply them to DNA our
first application with this technology
allows you to resolve copy number events
at the single-cell resolution revealing
cnv differences and heterogeneous
samples which are really hard to resolve
even with the most advanced informatics
in both the envy sequencing analysis or
in karyotype arrays so in this picture
here a breast tumor sample was dissected
and run through the single cell CMB
solution and every line in the heat map
represents a cell and the coloring means
the deviation from normal deployed cells
you can see that there is variation
within each portion of the tumor and
within it further on the top sample
there is a small percent of non normal
cells which wouldn't be able to be seen
in books in the analysis although this
has been applied with a cancer sample it
is also a tool that can be used to look
at Moses at the single cell level
the single-cell attack solution allows
for interrogation of open chromatin
sites in single nuclei for more result
understanding of gene regulatory
mechanisms and epigenetics here we want
to show this single-cell resolution of
attack to the well-established bulk
method and these are representative
tracts of open chromatin regions from
the gm12878 lymphoblastoid cell line and
this portion of the genome represents a
known region that has open chromatin
sites the upper orange tract represents
data gathered from 50,000 nuclear in
bulk where the lower green tract is
aggregated from about 600 individual
nuclei run on the chromium single cell
attack solution so even with data from
the 75 fold fewer nuclei the single cell
attack solution demonstrates a similar
sensitivity to that both ATAC sequencing
and the lower box shows the open
chromatin sites but at single-cell
resolution from the same sample as in
the aggregate Green above
and the next capability that is now
available for ordering is the future bar
coding technology with our immune
profiling solutions and applications
that we've started with are the
capability to map PCR okona types the
multiplex sets the peptide MHC molecules
which are antigen presenting molecules
and this is to understand the t-cell
specificity to the cellular level in the
picture to the left you'll see a t cell
that has specificity for a certain
antigen and has a peptide MHC dexter
make room in your Dex bound to it we
then put those labeled cells through the
chromium immune profiling solution and
are able to generate profiles that show
the krona type specific to the antigens
presented and in addition to having the
future barcode capability for our immune
profiling solution we also now have it
available for a single cell gene
expression solution and the applications
that can be enabled through this are
simultaneous measurements of gene
expression and cell surface proteins on
the same cell but also highly parallel
functional genomics with simultaneous
gene expression and CRISPR screening for
this feature barcode capability you can
actually measure up to four different
readouts in the same cell the one gene
expression of the cells to TCR and IG
paired receptor sequences three t-cell
specificity to antigens and four cell
surface proteins so this is a huge step
towards true multi-omics approaches
the newest announcement from 10x is how
we push the boundaries of our
single-cell gene expression solution
with improvements in chemistry and
consumables for up to 2 fold increase in
gene sensitivity in this set of data are
version 2 and version 3 gene expression
solution was run with a complex cell
type embryonic mouse heart you can see
in the chart that the gene sensitivity
is twofold greater at the standard reads
per cell and this improvement in gene
sensitivity gives greater experimental
design flexibility and allows to detect
more genes per cell without the need for
additional sequencing reads or one could
achieve the same cell and gene metrics
today with up to half the amount of
sequencing reads which means cost
savings or sequence even more to
maximize the number of genes detected
all of these solutions are available for
order and consists of our chromium
controller reagents and consumables and
easy to use pipeline and visualization
tools making it a straightforward for
anyone to incorporate these methods into
their experimental goals we hope that
when you're thinking about the
understanding of genomics
transcriptomics and epigenomics
in single cells and beyond you know that
10x genomic solutions are there to help
and answer those questions and with that
I would like to thank you very much for
your attention and I'll Pablo I'll help
a hand over to you
so thank you very much I'm Nika for the
very nice presentation about 10x
genomics and think alex is put a very
nice introduction to this webinar and of
course the biggest thanks goes out all
of you attending this webinar in
spending time with us
so single cell is a field that's really
close to my heart because before joining
Illumina around five years ago I used to
work with single-cell RNA sequencing and
it tremendous to see just how much this
field has evolved over the last couple
of years
in the short presentation I wanted to
briefly introduce how our sequencing
systems enable you to do a wide range of
single cell sequencing applications and
as this presentation will be very short
if you have any questions any particular
project you're planning you will
evaluate which sequencing options that
are available please don't hesitate to
get in touch with us we are more than
happy to assist
so why run single selves and this is
probably something that's familiar to
most of you but I wanted to go through
the short example just to make sure that
we are all on the same page so here you
see two collections of them a and B and
if you treat the cells in a bulk fashion
you see that the total number of this
ready transcript is 6 in both cases
so looking at the desk the bulk level
you might come to the conclusion that
case a and case B are exactly the same
but digging deeper having the single
health resolution you see that in case a
all the cells Express this ready
transcript or s in case B only a few
shall Express it to a very high level
whereas most of the cells are silent
by having single-cell resolution you're
able to tease case a and case B apart
in his mansion there have been
tremendous advances over the last couple
of years and we are also seeing a
tremendous increase in the number of
publications where singles and
sequencing has been used so it's being
widely used across many different areas
from cancer research to immunology from
stem cell research to neurobiology and
I'm really looking forward to hearing
the presentation by assistant professor
temple about how he has used this behind
in new tool
important to acknowledge that single
cell is not that one-size-fits-all
application there of course different
study aims different tissues different
organs and different biological
questions that require different numbers
of cells and of course there are also
different modalities to be studied for
example some cases you might want to
study RNA helicases DNA may be proteins
we are seeing that there is an avalanche
of new methods becoming available
allowing you to study more and more
facets of biology at the single cell
level and there is also a drive towards
multi onyx to study multiple modalities
for multiple levels of the central dogma
in individual thing single cells in a
very high throughput manner and one
example is the high tech or the reap
seek type of methods with which you can
study both the expression RNA and
protein simultaneously
no matter what you are interested in
studying we do have a sequencing system
a sequencing solution that matches your
output needs so we have systems from the
iseek 100 instrument giving you 4
million reads all the way up to Nova C
6000 instrument giving you 20 billion
reads and we strive for our systems to
be as flexible as possible so imagine
that you want to do a single cell deep
characterization study maybe you want to
take a look at 1,000 cells of a
particular cell type and sequence them
better quite high therefore 500 thousand
beats per cell - I'm getting
understanding of them in more detail so
the total sequencing output required
here is 500 million reads which is an
excellent fit for the s-prime flow cell
stored in over seek so the smallest flow
cells for the Nova see system but now
imagine that you also want to do am a
plussing study where you take 200
thousand cells from a particular tissue
from a particular organ to understand
the cellular composition of the tissue
of the Dorgan and you want to profile
those cell of the 50000 receptor the
total output required here is 10 billion
reads which is an excellent fit today
for the s4 flow cell for the Nova system
so the largest flows are available so
simply by selecting the most appropriate
level you are able to use the pneumatic
system for a number of different
applications
and I also wanted to highlight our I
seek 100 system this is as mentioned our
smallest sequencing system and as you
can see it gives you four million of
reads per round and this is too limited
for most single cell applications but
it's an excellent fit for library
quality control so you could call it to
control your single cell library on the
IC 100 system before running it on
for example Nova system
and in addition to the flexibility we
continuously strive to evolve our
sequencing systems to enable you to do
more using the existing systems these
are examples of technological advances
announced at the American Society of
Human Genetics annual meeting in October
2018 we demonstrated two times 250
rounds on both the IC and the no batik
systems
extending the platform capabilities and
the potential applications and perhaps
of more interest for the single-cell
field we release the new version of the
next week reagent kit and these have
improved robustness and slow cell
stability
I wanted to once again reiterate that
Illumina systems enable a wide range of
single cell sequencing applications so
if you have a particular project in mind
if you have any questions if you want to
find out which is the optimal system and
solution for your needs please don't
hesitate to get in touch as mentioned we
are more than happy to assist
and of course a big thank you for
joining us today
so hello everybody I'm very happy to
talk to you today about a phenotype
molding of stromal cells in the lung
tumor microenvironment and I'm also very
grateful to 10x and Illumina for
organizing this webinar just a very
quick disclaimer that the opinions
expressed here are mine and not those of
Illumina so today we are going to talk
about a lung tumor microenvironment and
as many many of you listening will
probably know a lung tumors do not only
consist of tumor cells they also contain
fibroblasts that provide support to
these cancer cells
there's endothelial cells that line the
blood vessels that supply nutrients and
oxygen to the tumor and there's a whole
host of immune cells that are attracted
to tumors and all of this happens in the
context of a normal lung so you have
also all the different alveolar cells
that are present normally in the lung
that are also it can also be found in
the lung tumor microenvironment so all
only all this makes up a very complex
cellular ecosystem and this is not
something that is purely out of
scientific interest this is also
therapeutically very important as many
of these cell types are established
targets for cancer therapies for example
t-cells are the targets of immunotherapy
and endothelial cells are the target of
anti-angiogenic therapy
but the question we were asking is
whether these are indeed all the cell
types that are present and whether they
form uniform populations and finally
also how they are affected by the tumor
microenvironment and to study this was
until recently very difficult but then
came along then X and single-cell RNA
sequencing and this allowed us to study
the diversity and heterogeneity of the
tumor micro-environment in a lot more
detail so to do this very briefly we
isolate the tumor samples as they come
came from the clinic we added protein s
and collagenous to them to digest away
the extracellular matrix and this
provided us with a single cell
suspension that we then took forward to
make libraries out of using the 10x
technologies a very brief overview of
the study that we've done so this role
treatment naive patients with non
metastatic non-small cell lung cancer we
focused our analysis on five different
patients that underwent primary lobe
resection for curative intent all of
these patients had ears non small cell
lung cancer of the squamous or the
adenoids subtype and some of them also
suffered from chronic obstructive
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease
over former smokers from these patients
we isolated 19 samples in total so four
came from the normal lung lobe and 15
came from the tumor so from every tumor
we isolated three different samples for
reasons which I will not discuss in
detail further during the current
presentation all in all from all these
samples we isolated a little over 50,000
cells and this per to sequence the
transcriptome of these 50,000 cells and
produce a little over 3 billion unique
transcripts which we then took forward
for analysis and to analyze these
and let me let me just briefly explain
to you how this is typically done I know
that a lot of you that are listening
will notice but transcriptomes or single
cells are analyzed or are depicted at
least often using t-sne blocks so the
disputed stochastic neighbor embedding
plots in which every dot represents the
cell and the closer different cells are
together the more similar they are in
terms of gene expression pattern so when
we look at established marker genes we
can identify for example alveolar cells
on your left and ethereal cells
epithelial cells fibroblasts which are
collagen positive B cells myeloid cells
T cells and apart from those of course
also the cancer cells now before we dive
into these analysis we first wanted to
do a little QC and for this we compared
the classical methods to do RNA
sequencing this is bulk RNA sequencing
with our single cell transcriptome so we
collated all single cells from one
sample and and compared the expression
of those collated cells to the bulk
transcriptome and this revealed that for
some marker genes such as col1a1 there
was an enrichment in the bulk whereas
other marker genes showed the depletion
in the bulk and enrichment in the single
cell RNA sequencing this was something
that was not only evident from the
single marker genes also when we did
gene ontology analysis for genes that
were typically done regulated in things
in the single cell dataset or genes are
typically up regulated in the single
cell dataset we observed a similar
pattern so tease it or downregulated
were often enriched in extracellular
matrix proteins whereas genes that were
upregulated were very often involved for
example in T cell activation
we also quantified the number of cells
in bulk mRNA sequencing
or we estimated these based on the
marker genes that we identified and this
also showed us the same better namely
that T cells are enriched and B cells
are enriched in myeloid cells tend to be
enriched in the single-cell RNA
sequencing data set resolve the other
cells and cancer cells and heal
yourselves and fibroblasts in particular
tend to be depleted from the single-cell
RNA sequencing and this probably simply
reflects the difference in this
efficiency so some cell types such as
fibroblasts are much more difficult to
dissociate when compared to T cells and
so probably that this is why they are
under represented in the single cell RNA
sequencing that said overall the
expression pattern between was very
similar between bulk and single cell so
we were happy to proceed and to continue
with our analysis and this was done
using Seurat we tested a number of
different analysis platforms that are
out there we tried a c3 RCA cider and
also scenic and out of these when we
analyzed that when we looked at quality
metric the nmi we saw that suet in
general produce the most consistent
results out of all the platforms
although a c3 was also quite good as you
can appreciate from the prop on your
lower left so we continued with Serrat
and with in cigarettes when we performed
clustering of ourselves we always used a
resolution that was quite conservative
and the resolution and all the other
clustering parameters that we used were
chosen so that they were robust to
changes in the parameter setting so that
the results that we obtained were
actually quite robust when we now go
back to the t-sne plot that i discussed
that i showed to you earlier and we
color code every cell according to the
sample of origin you can already
appreciate that for some of these
clusters
I highlight the cluster names for you on
the right so for some of these clusters
you can appreciate that they are
predominantly tumor derived and this
goes obviously for cancer cells but also
for example for b-cells
and to a lesser extent for fibroblasts
whereas other clusters are predominantly
non-malignant tissue derived and this is
for example true for the alveolar cells
when we now look at the panel in the
middle where we are have color coded
every cell according to which patient
the cell comes from you can appreciate
that most of the stromal cell types are
actually derived from multiple patients
so they share transcriptomes across
different tumors in contrast the cancer
cells tend to be patient specific so we
have one cluster that it originates from
patient five one cluster is originated
from patient four one two entry so in
conclusion cancer cells tend to be
predominantly tumor derived and they
cluster per patient whereas other cell
clusters tend to be more mixed in terms
of sample in patient and as I mentioned
to you earlier already the recovery of
these cells tends to be cell type
dependent next we wanted to know how
homogeneous these different stromal cell
types are and how they are affected by
being in the tumor microenvironment and
so to do this we analyzed each cell type
again but independently so to illustrate
this a bit more clearly we take all 1592
endothelial cells which are closing five
positive marked in red on the left and
weari cluster them and this allows us to
ask you know which expression patterns
allow us to distinguish different types
of individual cells and do they actually
cluster separately the answer is of
course yes otherwise we wouldn't be
sitting here the end our analysis
reveals a strong influence of the tumor
microenvironment in that normal
endothelial cells and tumor endothelial
cells tend to cluster separately so this
is can be appreciated on the right
overall we ident
five six different clusters of
endothelial cells two clusters were
mainly normal tissue derived two
clusters remain the tumor derived there
was one mixed cluster that was mainly
composed of low-quality endothelial
cells and then cluster six which is also
on the rest of two different tumor or
two different sample origins
now when we look at marker genes that
are known two more different types of
glial cells we can already tell this
cluster 6 is actually corresponds to
lymphatic endothelial cells because
these are protoplanet positive result
the other clusters mark our mark by
flipped one and this is a marker of
endothelial cells that normally line the
blood vessel so these are blood
endothelial cells now because we have
the transcriptomes of endothelial cells
that are derived from non malignant
tissue and from tumor tissue we can
specifically look for marker genes that
mark either normal endothelial cells or
tumor endothelial cells and I've
highlighted two of those for you on this
slide 22 a is a marker of normal
endothelial cells to be identified and
it is PT - specifically marks tumor
endothelial cells these are just two of
the markers that you identified but
we've identified over a dozen four
doesn't for each of these and this
allowed us to turn to bulk RNA
sequencing data that was characterized
in the Cancer Genome Atlas and here we
are looking at the aggregate of about a
thousand three hundred samples that
either were derived from lung from
squamous tumors or adenoids tumors and
as you can appreciate normal endothelial
cell markers tend to show a higher
expression in normal lung tissue when
compared to tumors whereas tumor
endothelial cell markers tend to show a
higher expression in tumors than in the
normal lung so this also validates a bit
marker genes that we identify we've also
used immunofluorescence to see whether
we can indeed identify specific
subpopulations of endothelial cells as
being marked by one of these new marker
genes and here we are showing for
example results for ack r1 which is a
marker of endothelial cell cluster 3
this is a tumor endothelial cell cluster
and as you can appreciate on the top ACK
r1 only marks a subset of the cells that
are close in five positive so chlorine 5
is marked in
whereas if you look at the lower panels
for the non-malignant immunofluorescence
there again you can see that ack r1
marks only a subset of the endothelial
cells but there's a lot more endothelial
cells in the non-malignant sample when
compared to the tumor sample so this is
something that is also shown in the
quantification which is shown at the
bottom so there's a lot more clothing 5
positive cells in the normal sample when
compared to the tumor samples but the
fraction of endothelial cells that are
that is actually ack r1 positive so ack
r1 is a marker for cluster 3 tumor
endothelial cell marker so the fraction
event for these endothelial cells is
much higher in tumor samples than in
normal samples knob viously identifying
marker genes is all very interesting but
we wanted to understand the phenotypes
of and the differences in phenotype
between normal and tumor endothelial
cells and to look at the phenotypes
ourselves we squirt their expression
using 50 hallmark pathways with a
hallmark pathways these are sets of
genes described in the molecular
signature database from the broad and
that are generally agreed upon as being
important in cell biology each of these
hallmark pathway gene sets were next
scored using tinted variation analysis
in every single cell and this produces a
picture that looks somewhat like this so
the more blue a cell is the higher the
expression of for example the MiG target
pathways now I'm not showing you the Mik
target pathway here just by coincidence
indeed when you look at the Mik targets
this is the pathway that shows the
strongest enrichment in tumor versus
normal so all the cells which are on
your upper left these are in fact tumor
endothelial cells the cells which are on
your lower right is our normal
endothelial cells and as you can
appreciate there's a lot more big target
pathway activity in tumor endothelial
cells than in normal endothelial cells
in line with this also when we look at
make expression on its own we see that
this is much higher in tumor endothelial
cells than in normal and attune yourself
now make is a very interesting protein
and one of the it's been studied a lot
and one of the things it classically
does it is that it gives metabolic
changes to cells that feed back to
global RNA production so in other words
cells that have a high make expression
tend to have a lot more RNA production
than cells that have a low make
expression now because we do 10x and
with 10x we can identify unique
transcripts and we can count those
unique transcripts in each and every
single cell this allowed us to look at
the phenotypic outputs of increased big
expression namely how many unique
transcripts can we actually identify in
every in each cell and again in line
with an increase in make expression in
tumor and athelia cells we see that we
detect a lot more unique transcripts in
tumor endothelial cells and in normal
individual cells even though samples for
sequence at a comparable depth and in
other words tumor endothelial cells are
indeed transcriptionally more active all
of this
this may be sensitive to my keen
ambition and there's at least some hints
in the literature to support this notion
indeed it has been shown quite a while
ago already that lick is essential for
vascular Genesis and angiogenesis for
example during development when we now
go back to our 50 hallmark pathways and
we look all the way at the bottom so
which is a pathway that is moves down
regulated in tumor and Odile yourself we
noticed something very remarkable namely
that the inflammatory response was most
unregulated in tumor endothelial cells
why do I say this is remarkable
well because tumors tend to be very
inflammatory when we look now look more
in depth at which genes are actually
down regulated we note the lot of the
genes are involved in antigen
presentation and in immune cell homing
so we have for example I cam 1 which is
a protein that is expressed on
endothelial cells and then allow the
immune cells to adhere to the
endothelial cells that line the blood
vessels and subsequently to penetrate
the tissue and deal with the
inflammation as it is present to
understand this a bit more it's
important to realize that your blood
vessels actually form the primary
interface between the tissues that they
profuse and the immune system as it is
going through your bloodstream and when
there is inflammation in a tissue this
inflammatory signal is typically relayed
through endothelial cells that line the
blood vessel and they then presents
signals to the immune system that allow
the immune system to recognize that
there is inflammation and to penetrate
the tissue so all these data suggested
this rewiring of tumor and Otilio cells
contributes to the immunosuppressive
phenotype of tumors and that if we can
make tumor endothelial cells more normal
that this may help with immunotherapy
and there's at least some suggestions
that's combining until anti-angiogenic
therapy and immunotherapy that this
might actually be a very successful
strategy and also in line with this is
this seminal paper that was published
now a decade ago which show that
Vascular normalization in fact the mutes
it promotes immune destruction so when
we make tumor endothelial cells more
like normal and ethereal cells this
actually promotes immune destruction of
tumors
now to understand why these tumor
endothelial cells show such a divergent
transcriptome from normal material cells
we turned to scenic and this is a new
method that was developed by some very
clever people down the corridor here
from the lab of standards and what
scénic actually does is in a first step
it looks for genes which are Co
regulated so you have here genes which
are either always up regulated in a Cell
or either always down regulated in a
cell and then the very clever trick is
it scénic looks for conserved
transcription factor binding site or
conserved motifs upstream of genes that
tend to be Co regulated and it looks for
specifically for those motifs that are
present at each of these genes in the
set of core regulated genes scénic also
looks for the transcription factor that
recognizes this conserved motif and in
that way it can build a regulan so this
is a set of genes and transcription
factor that are all Co regulated and we
can score each cell for the activity of
this regulome and then in a second in a
last phase contrast cells that have a
high regular expression versus cells
that have a low regular on expression
and when we do this for normal and tumor
endothelial cells we can identify
different transcription factors that are
interactive in one or in the other and
the most striking here is the Faustian
pathway which appeared to be very
strongly down regulated in tumor and
material cells and why is this an
interesting pathway
well because from the literature we know
that four-engine can actually activate I
cam 1 so this is the protein that was
involved in immune cell homing so when
we lose four-engine we in turn lose ICAM
and this suggests that lots of false
engine may underlie the
immunosuppressive phenotype
of tumor endothelial cells so to
summarize tumor endothelial cells are
very distinct from normal endothelial
cells that regulate transcription
chromic activation they don't regulate
the immune cell attraction pathways and
they show decreased Faust's and general
activity so apart from endothelial cells
there's also a lot of other stromal
cells that we've looked at in this study
and let me just briefly mention to you
what we've found in the t-cells because
this is also quite quite interesting so
we've looked at almost 25,000 T cells T
cells make up by far the most abundant
subpopulation that we could I get that
recruit isolate and when we cluster
these T cells we find actually nine
different clusters of T cells most of
these are strongly enriched in the tumor
microenvironment as you can appreciate
from this slide and when we look at
known marker genes we can tell that we
have identified natural killer cells cd8
positive T cells cd4 right regulatory T
cells exhausted T cells which are a
subpopulation of the cd8 positive T
cells and then finally there's the
proliferating T cells which are on your
lower right so are these all the T cell
subtypes that we could identify and what
about other known T cell types well when
we look at for example cluster six so
this is the trust which is on top there
and when we look at the over plotting
density so how many cells are in every
quadrant on the plot we see that in fact
cluster six probably consists of two
different clusters and also when we look
at CD 3 expression we see that only one
of these clusters is marked by CD 3 so
the upper one of these clusters actually
corresponds to NK cells and not NK t
cells
so why are these two clusters than
clustered together well quite simply
probably because both are NK cell so
they
execute the same functions and they
shared the vast majority of their
transcriptome this result also
highlights that we here cluster cells by
function and not simply by their limits
as you all know NK cells are part of the
innate immune system whereas NKT cells
are part of the adaptive immune system
apart from these we also identified LC
one like cells and gamma delta T cells
which are part of cd8 T cell cluster 2
and overall the fact that we combine
known cell types within one cluster
strongly argues against over that we did
over clustering that we artificially
generated new cell types so can we also
identify new T cell types well there's
at least one that I thought was very
interesting namely this subpopulation of
cd8 t-cells that doesn't express grams
and B but that doesn't express grams I'm
Kay well there are some hints in the
literature to suggest that these are
immature cd8 t-cells I think there's a
lot more work to be done to understand
the exact biology of these sub cluster
and likewise their cd4 T cells that
express CXC L 13 of which the function
has been hinted at in the literature but
that is for the moment still quite
unclear when we look at the marker genes
and quantify their expression in bulk
RNA sequencing data from TCGA we can
again recapitulate a different
distribution of these clusters between
normal and tumor cells and when we look
at the pathway activity of each of these
and this is shown here on the right and
I would say that by and large being in
the tumor microenvironment has a similar
effect on each of these subpopulations
of T cells
so when we look at the individual
clusters of cd8 t-cells it is very clear
that there there are striking
differences between those that are
derived from the tumor and those that
come from the normal tissue so plus rate
for example shows a very strong
increased proliferation when it is in
the tumor versus clusters for an H o
strong increase in interferon signalling
and in a low graft rejection the
allograft rejection pathway is quite
interesting because it was composed of
genes that are typically up regulated
when there is an organ transplant that
is being rejected so in the context of
the tissue this probably corresponds to
new new antigens that are presented
specifically in the tumor and that do
not correspond to the normal genetic
makeup of the tumor host in line with
this clusters 4 & 8 also up regulate
strongly checkpoint molecules so we have
pd-1 cd8 the ctla-4 and lagg-3 which are
all up regulated in clusters 4 & 8 and
this is together with a stronger
correlation of t-cell activity
and as shown by in the up regulation of
grands I'm expression so what this
actually allowed us to do was to
correlate t-cell activity as measured by
the activity of granzymes with all other
genes that are specifically expressed in
T cells and what this reveals is that XV
all the known or gordon on check
checkpoints that are either accepted as
therapeutic targets at or ordered in
clinical trials are actually very
strongly correlating with gran time
expression across these 25,000 T cells
and apart from these there's also a lot
of new potential targets that we propose
are potentially also new C D and targets
for immunotherapy so in conclusion we
identify all the known and some perhaps
unknown or less well characterized
t-cell subtypes most t-cells activate
similar pathways in the tumor
microenvironment sub clusters or cd8
positive T cells clearly have different
pathways which are active depending on
whether or not they are part of the
tumor microenvironment and known as well
as novel candidate checkpoint molecules
correlate with the cd8 positive T cell
activity
so finally let me just briefly show you
some of the data that we obtained for
fibroblasts because we were quite
excited when we saw this fibroblasts are
typically considered to be a quite
uniform cell type and they're very
difficult to study in isolation in part
because they tend to adopt a plastic
adherent phenotype when you try to
culture them so when we look in vivo
what expression patterns actually
distinguish these different types of
fiberglass we saw in fact that there we
could identify seven different clusters
of fibroblasts these are mostly enriched
in the tumor microenvironment but they
show a remarkable phenotypic diversity
and this was particularly true when we
looked at the expression of
extracellular matrix molecules and
collagen in particular so as you can
appreciate from the pen on the right
while most of the clusters expressed
collagen six cluster two specifically
expressed collagen for cluster five
specifically expressed collagen 5
cluster 7 specifically expressed
collagen 8 etc etc so each of these
fibroblast types
apparently expresses its own unique
extracellular matrix repertoire
and overall we move from a situation
where a little over a dozen different
cell types in the lung tumor
microenvironment are recognized to this
situation where we see 25 52 different
types of cell types and importantly this
was not limited to the five patients
that we studied because when we try to
replicate this in three additional
patient samples we could recover 45 of
these 52 different stromal cell subtypes
now because we have marker genes for
each of these we can also look at how
they affect you more biology I wanted
for example for in very interestingly
noticed was that they are strongly anti
correlated their presence is strongly
anti correlated with mutational burden
now here we don't think this is actually
part of the normal biology which we
think that this actually reflects errors
in mutation calling where a higher
stromal cell admixture leads to a lower
allele frequency and more difficulties
to identify mutations very interestingly
stromal cell abundance was also
correlated to patient survival in
particular in squamous tumors we noted
that high abundance of stromal cells was
was detrimental for patient survival and
so for example when we look at certain
types of epithelial cells or alveolar
cells we note that higher abundance of
these cells was associated with poorer
survival and this was observed in TCGA
data and could be replicated in two
additional studies
so to summarize we I generated the first
comprehensive catalogue of the lung
tumor microenvironment in which we
detected 52 different cell subtypes and
observed for example the striking
fiberglass heterogeneity we saw a
remarkable influence of the tumor
microenvironment on endothelial cells
and also on my load cells these are data
which I hadn't had time to discuss to
you today and we identified specific
marker genes that can serve as
biomarkers for stromal therapies we also
identified specific pathways and
transcription factors that are active in
the tumor microenvironment and that may
represent a new therapeutic
vulnerabilities and then finally the
relative abundance of cell subtypes is
correlated with patient out
if you want to learn more about this all
of this was published recently in Nature
Medicine within this publication you can
also find the link to our website on
which we have put all our datasets
available and you can upload them from
there into scope which is a graphical
user interface that allows you to
interactively explore the data that we
have generated here and then finally you
can also come to a conference that we
are organizing next year in March where
leaders in the field as well as people
from for example 10x and alumina will
come and discuss the next top topics in
next-generation sequencing
so with that I would like to end let me
just briefly still acknowledge everybody
that contributed to the study and in
particular detail numbers from the
Flemish Institute of biotechnology Stan
Artin saga who contributed scenic and
everybody from the hospital let's
contribute the Thames and of course all
of you for your attention thank you
you
Thank You Bernard and you get and dr.
Zajac for your informative presentations
we will now start the last Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the answer question box located
on the far left to your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is what is the most
robust way to normalize read numbers
between single cells we observe huge
differences in housekeeping gene
expression and mitochondrial transcript
seem to be influenced by our treatment
I so the way we normalized read numbers
between single cells is just initially a
very classical normalization to the
total read count within that single cell
the fact that you see huge differences
in housekeeping gene expression is not
something that we typically see what I
do know is that mitochondrial
transcripts tend to change in expression
levels as cells undergo apoptosis
because then these mitochondria
transcripts tend to get more prevalent
so if you see a high level of
mitochondrial transcripts then this
could perhaps signal that there's an
increase in apoptosis of your cells you
can normalize out for example increased
mitochondrial transcript expression or
normalize out batch effects using
classical models which are implemented
also in servants so maybe that's
something that you could try to overcome
this the reason why you see these
differences is probably in part
technical and probably in part
biological so it's definitely something
to take care of and to look out for
now our next question is is this data
published yet so there the answer is yes
as I mentioned in the presentation all
these data is published in Nature
Medicine a couple of months ago and as I
also mentioned you can go to our website
download all the analyzed data or you
can get in touch if you really want to
get the gene expression matrices
directly and you can also go to scope
where you can inter interactively play
with all the data and it's simply
something that the in my experience
people find really quite handy and
people than to really enjoy doing so if
they're if there's any particular cell
type that you're interested in or any
particular gene or set of genes that you
want to explore then I would suggest
that you go to scope and just see for
yourself
now what was the depth of sequencing per
cell
so this is something that is highly
variable in fact so we tend to aim for
quite a good sequencing depth let me see
if I can recall the numbers of the top
of my head I think we went to two about
[Music]
let's say a hundred million reads per
thousand cells or 50 million 50 million
200 million reads per thousand cells
again this is something that is highly
variable also not just because the so
the number of reads per cell tends to be
very very variable not just because of
how much sequencing effort you put into
it but also because the number of reads
that you recover from every cell varies
tremendously both for technical reasons
I don't know maybe less transcripts are
captured in one compared to the other
let's say microwell and on the other
hand the there's also simple biological
differences between different cell types
and some cell types just on average to
express less transcripts than others and
cancer cells for example tend to show
very high transcript numbers whereas for
example T cells showed show on average a
bit lower transcript numbers so there's
no simple answer to the question but you
know that that I guess as much as I can
as I can meaningfully meaningfully say
about that
now let's move on to our next question
how fixed are these cellular phenotypes
are these truly cell types or do they
represent self States now that that's a
question that I get quite frequently and
it's it's for sure it's at least in part
a matter of semantics you know what do
you call a cell type and what you call a
self State I think it depends a bit on
what domain you are working in if you're
working an immunology than a cell type
is something else and when you're
working in embryology for example or
when you're working in neurology cell
types tend to be very much defined by by
function whereas in other domains cell
types tend to be defined by for example
by morphology so whether they are really
cell types or cell states that's
something that I think the jury is out
there now for the moment I cannot so say
for sure whether they are cell types or
cell States whether they are
interconvertible or not it's something
that I think is a very interesting
question and something that we are
definitely very keen to explore further
in future studies
we are getting some great questions in
today so let's move on with a couple
more could you give some details about
scenic can we use it with bulk RNA seek
data or only single-cell RNA seek data
so scenic is something that is
specifically designed for single-cell
data because it really needs a lot of
independent signals to identity
independent let's say samples and every
single cell for scenic is one sample so
it needs a lot of different samples to
identify sets of coagulated teens so
these are sets of genes which tend to be
either up or down in a subset of
yourself that genes which are highly
co-regulated so I don't think you can
use this with bulk RNA seek data another
tool that was developed and that in my
hands at least works very well is called
Isis target it was developed by the same
lab that also developed Scenic's or the
lab of stain eyes and Isis target
similarly looks for
[Music]
enriched transcription factor binding
motifs upstream of sets of co-regulated
teens it just applies a bit more of us
if I remember correctly it applies a bit
more of a stringent threshold on what is
considered a conserved motif
one of the very neat things about scenic
and this is something that you cannot
directly do with Isis target is because
in scenic you also have the differential
expression of the transcription factor
itself you can directly link the
expression of that transcription factor
to and the increased activity of genes
that all share upstream the motif that
normally is the target for this
transcription factor so it what seening
does really a great job at connecting
the transcription factor to the
transcription factor binding motif that
is upstream of your set of core
regulated genes
and it does look like we have time for
one more question do you have any
insight in the spatial organization of
these cells where are they in the tumor
with regards to each other so we have
some insight I I know that people are
developing ways to get a lot higher
resolution insight in this patient for
example with with spatial
transcriptomics technologies or with
physic we don't have those data at hand
for us what we did do I mentioned this
early on in the presentation that where
every tumor we isolated three different
samples and in fact one of these three
samples originated from the tumor core
another of these three samples came from
the edge of the tumor and one was in
between so this allowed us to get a feel
for how the distribution of different
cells is within the tumor and this
clearly showed that as one would expect
the tumor cells cancer cells that they
tend to be enriched in the tumor core
and that they are a bit depleted from
the tumor edge and vice versa that many
of the stromal cells but you know
clearly not all and if you want to get
more information on this I suggest you
go to the paper but that many stromal
cells and any particular alveolar cells
tend to be enriched at the edge of the
tumor likewise we could see that cancer
cells that are at the tumor core tend to
be more hypoxic than cancer cells which
are at the edge of the tumor and again
this is something which is pretty much
in line with what is described in the
literature so we have a rough idea about
you know where these different cell
types are but if we want to get a more
fine-grained information on how these
different cell types are let's say
juxtaposed and whether cell type a that
we described is associated with cell
type B or whether it's associated with
cell type C then you need to go either
to spatial methods or you have to rely
on the recently described Co expression
of
the agonist receptor interactions I
believe there was a paper in cell that
was published a couple of months ago
that looked at the development of
basophils in in the lung with an
excellent paper and if this is something
that you're truly interested in the
night I suggest you go and have a look
at that one
thank you again for nard Anika and
doctors a jack for your time today and
reportin research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsors alumina
and 10x genomics for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the odds advance period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information that you
provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through May of 2019 labyrinths will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye